immediately on my left is Eva Empson Eva
completed a PhD in biochemistry at the
University of Toronto she blogs about
science in art and pop culture at
Eastern blot net and about the culture
of science especially online culture at
expression patterns on nature network
Tedrow cell is a writer former English
professor mom and sometime public
intellectual she's taught at research
universities community colleges and
elementary schools and is currently
these I think are her words in her bio
thinking really hard about her next paid
gig Claire Potter is professor of
history in American Studies at Wesleyan
University in Middletown Connecticut she
specializes in United States political
history queer studies in the history of
gender sex and feminism she's the author
of war on crime bandits g-men and the
politics of mass culture which was
published by rutgers university press
she's currently finishing a book about
William Archibald Dunning and she's
beginning a third book about feminist
anti-pornography campaigns in the 1970s
and 1980s she can also be found at her
blog tenured radical I started blogging
while I was doing my PhD in biochemistry
at at the University of Toronto and I
just wanted to talk a bit about science
in general to a public general audience
because I felt that a lot of people
didn't really know what I was doing in
the lab and why I spend so much time in
the lab and while I was doing that I am
I found that it created some
opportunities for writing so I actually
decided after I finished my PhD to not
go on and do a postdoc but instead do
more science writing and I'm currently
applying for jobs in the more science
communication sphere so connecting
scientists rather than being one myself
and that's what my blog basically helped
me decide I started my blog I think I
was on the market and I'd had I'd had my
son while I was finishing my
dissertation and I'd been really active
on a form called him mama and there was
a big brouhaha over kind of an
articulated racism of a lot of the woman
on the
on the forums and eventually they shut
down the forms because of people who are
moderating it just didn't want to deal
with the headaches anymore and the big
flame wars so a bunch of us went off and
started live journals and kind of links
to each other and did that kind of
little community thing but more and more
as i was kind of moving away from
thinking primarily in terms of being
online as a mom two things i wanted to
talk about about my job search and
academia as well and my kind of
ambivalence about identifying as an
academic i wanted a more public forum so
I started a blog spot blog and I was
talking with my old college roommate one
night online and we were trying to come
up with line with a title that was kind
of a snappy title so I have to credit
her bitch PhD was her suggestion not
mine but it it turned out to be really
kind of a good snappy title although I
hear tell that sometimes it's it's
blocked from certain public library such
um but it's it's really evolved I think
over the years i think it's five years
old now maybe going on my sixth year now
i have co bloggers i didn't use to i
haven't taught or I had a tenure-track
job for three years and I was very
careful about my anonymity at the time
and then when I left that job to move
back to the west coast of the United
States I got a little more open about my
identity and stuff and so now my kind of
rule of thumb is officially bitch PhD as
a pseudonym and on the blog I never
mentioned my own name but I'm not I
don't worry about it elsewhere um oh
okay what I was saying is that I don't
use my name on my blog bitch PhD is her
own kind of character basically a
persona my dissertation work was on 18th
century periodical publication and I was
specifically interested in the authorial
persona for these 18th century
periodicals whether it's the Tattler and
the spectator but there were also a lot
of really little ones some by women some
by people who we still don't know who
they were so more i blogged the more
interested I got both because
of my own kind of research in this field
but also in terms of the constant
arguments about whether people should be
allowed to post anonymously on the
internet which comes up every once in a
while in that that weird kind of author
positioning where your pseudonymous as
opposed to properly uh nonnamous right
there's a there's an ongoing persona
that has some kind of credibility so I'm
very firmly on the idea that people
should be allowed to post anonymously
but in any case the topics of the blog
now our mom's stuff a lot of the time
political stuff still because I'm still
very interested in that my co blogger
Sibyl vane just accepted a tenure-track
job and so she's kind of the academic
right now and my other two co bloggers
one is a lawyer and the other works for
nonprofit and I am currently as a matter
of fact it's funny that I'd forgotten it
in my bio i said i was thinking really
hard about my next paid gig but i'm
actually in the process of having just
been drafted to teach a writing course
for one of the local community colleges
and i haven't actually officially told
them i'll do it but i'm getting emails
from them about your 101 course and all
of this kind of stuff and the course is
already six weeks into the semester so
I'm extreme I'm really not sure I want
to take this on but I have a feeling
that when i get back i'm getting it up
in front of a classroom next week kind
of you know flying by the seat of my
pants so i guess that's my next pay kick
today i am close to my third what we
call blogoversary which is three years
from my my first post on october 17 2006
when i explained to my as-yet unknown
audience that quote long ago when the
new right decided to undermine the
intellectual foundations of the nation
one of the big charges made by radical
neo-cons was that universities will full
of tenured radicals who were
indoctrinating the youth of america the
not-so-big secret of course is that
universities and their faculties are far
from radical and the tenure is one of
the features of university life that
makes academics cautious at best
conservative at least so of course I
called mice
tenured radical and my blog was going to
solve this problem I can't say whether
my blog has actually changed anything in
the world but I do know that it has
changed me I become interested in the
uses of new technology for teaching and
scholarship in how technology alters
public conversations and how it does not
and in what it means to create a
scholarly arena where people can
disagree about ideas across time space
and status but blogging is first and
foremost about writing and writing in a
way that forget foregrounds play as well
as intellect this makes blogging
fundamentally different from how we were
all brought up to write in graduate
school which is that writing is our
principal work think about it one of the
earliest conventions we learn as
graduate students is to greet a new
person not by asking what are you
writing but by saying what are you
working on in a book I would recommend
to all of you and lamotte's bird by bird
Lamont goes on at hilarious length about
hating the act of writing this is a
situation familiar to many scholars and
one often accentuated for women our
institutions are all sexist to a greater
or lesser degree and the lack of
sustained feminist critique yes they are
the lack of sustained feminist critique
in the real world often reduces
structural problems that prevent us from
writing to a set of random anecdotal
grievances now part of why lamotte's
book appeals to me is that she talks
about this problem in a funny and not a
tragic way and this was a lesson I took
to my blogging about the Academy there
is virtually no academic script that
does not relate the difficulties of
one's writing career as having a tragic
and permanently damaging outcome such
outcomes might include not finishing a
dissertation the loss of a job or worse
if you really imagine yourself as a
writer the fear that you may never write
again what Lamont argues is that there
is no way to solve the problem of
writing
to write and to do it every day let me
repeat you must write every day blogging
helped me do that my essays have drawn a
broad audience within and outside the
Academy including a military wife an
oilman in Dubai some sock puppets who
live in Brooklyn and a manic woman who
writes practically in poetry and calls
herself the diva who I actually think is
probably a man many academic bloggers
gather a devoted cadre of like-minded
followers who advise and encourage them
this can be particularly helpful to
those who are assistant professors or
graduate students when they must cope
with anxiety or bad news one young
medievalist new kid on the hallway did
not have her contract renewed at third
year review new kid received an
outpouring of sympathy the kind of thing
I can say from experience that you are
not likely to get from your actual
colleagues both because it is awkward
and because you are hiding in your
office weeping but as she worked out her
final year moved to a visiting job and
then went on to law school she was also
able to draw on a substantial network of
junior and senior people for advice
about how to navigate these transitions
which brings me back to the question of
anonymity which is something we may want
to discuss more fully anonymity allows
people many of whom are untenured to
write about volatile and contentious
issues and to establish a clear boundary
between their academic writing and their
blogging as i said earlier i began
anonymously and came out about six
months into my career as the tenured
radical i came out for a variety of
reasons but principally because i had
been unmasked at my own institution and
had been for at least three months
before i discovered it and i also came
out because i came to believe at that
point the remaining anonymous or
pseudonymous had led me to make ethical
compromise as i would not otherwise have
made coming out also got me got my work
to a wider audience i have been invited
to join group blogs right for print and
internet publications for money beyond
panels about blogging like this one
a cluster on feminist blogging for an
academic journal and i have met really
interesting people i have been linked to
and written for a variety of prestigious
publications on the right and on the
left such as national review online The
Village Voice american historical
association perspectives online I don't
know whether they're on the right or the
left the American Federation of Teachers
weblog inside higher ed and The
Chronicle of Higher Education in other
words I am red which is the principal
thing you want as a writer so in
addition to making me think harder write
more and I think write better I have in
conventional and unconventional ways
acquired what every academic and every
writer wants an audience what blogging
also allowed me to do was to think
seriously and productively about what
brought me to this profession in the
first place and work specifically to
make that thing happen in a new way
blogging allows me to write short pieces
work on form voice and getting complex
ideas across to an audience that I need
to entice every day in order to keep
them reading I sometimes compared it to
a pianist playing scales to the extent
that blogging is not perhaps the most
serious scholarly form to take it
seriously is to become a better writer
and a better thinker I write every day
not just on weekends and in the summer
as I often did when writing was the work
that came last because it required so
much more focus and commitment this is
obviously reshaped my writing practice
time spent doing teaching or chairing is
time when I am taking a break from
writing and not the other way around
even if large projects are completed
slowly to write every day is to keep
continuity in my creative habits that
nurtures a sense of connection to my
intellect I've come to embrace what is a
generative but often unpleasant reality
of the scholarly world given our system
of high-stakes evaluation that sometimes
there are people who really hate what
you believe is your best work and you
need to listen to them anyway as a
blogger I also get to be a historian who
engages reg
larly with what happened yesterday or
contemporary history as I call it a
messy and exhilarating business that
said this kind of intellectual work on
the internet is considered highly
suspect by many scholars my age and
older in part because there are
virtually no rules that govern blogging
and the university world is obsessed
with rules and the respectability that
comes with following the rules blogging
is also an activity associated most
strongly with the young which makes a
middle-aged scholar blogger like myself
even more suspect I've had conversations
with some colleagues in which you would
have thought they were talking to
someone who had taken up competitive
skateboarding at the age of 50 the
comparison may be an apt one but if so
I'm having the best kind of middle-aged
crisis because I am constantly learning
new things blogging has it is true
involve me in some unpleasant
interactions in the university world
which I'd be happy to talk about however
in addition to connecting me to
intelligent people outside the Academy
it has also included me in a diverse
intellectual circle of scholars most of
them younger scholars who know things
that I don't know this in turn has
allowed me to re-engage with older
colleagues with a sharpened sense of
consciousness about what higher
education and the community of scholars
ought to be doing for and with those who
are its future and I truly believe that
younger people are the future and that
technology is that way for older people
to connect to them best which again I
can talk about when we're done
questions that I have that I can
certainly use to get going as a pair of
issues that's heard for me to separate
first of all a punch Cheryl spinner has
asked a scholarly women bloggers what
does the student it mean to you that you
consider going fight around a and why
choose a pseudonym like Teddy radical
verbiage PhD in fact that issues about
feminism and paired question a question
that I like to juxtapose at any rate is
for carolyn johnson who asks what are
the boundaries for blogging for
academics who do not have tenured
positions and she was added the
observation weak ones academic freedom
to do not want to risk our blogs that
negatively impacting our hiring
potential so i know for a lot of grad
students and untenured faculty of these
are issues well perhaps but those to you
is she is the question about you turn it
was versus claiming and identity that
the line with a real world identity and
also the question about different stages
of academia and the ways that stage that
you're at a better choice you make i
chose the name tenured radical because i
thought it was funny and my partner is
every once and while says to me you know
you better stay out of the way of that
kari nelson man because you stole the
title of his book and every once in a
while I do wonder like if I run into
kari nelson is he really going to be mad
or as he is good humoured as he seems to
be I thought it was funny and I'm
actually shocked that I got it but but
it has sort of become me on a certain
level I know there's not actually that
much difference between my personality
and my blog personality and and I think
of tenured radical as being sort of a
contradiction in terms which is how I
think of my position in the Academy in
many ways is as a contradiction in terms
as an out lesbian as a feminist and as
someone who actually in lots of ways
doesn't believe in in tenure which I
don't want to divert our conversation by
talking about that but I'm also
particularly at this historical moment
very glad that I have it
and and that it does in fact permit me a
certain freedom to to say what I think
and I say a certain freedom not not
complete freedom I think the question of
what what kind of relation your blog
actually might have to your career is a
really really front one and something
that everybody has to decide for
themselves perhaps it's just my
personality but I found that I was way
too unbuttoned when I was pseudonymous
it was it was much easier for me to
displace all kinds of things that I
would not say to people's faces onto the
blog and and because I deal with
contentious academic issues I think it
was very important for me to deal with
that I think there's a related issue
which i think is a problem with
anonymity and pseudonymity which is sort
of what I mentioned before people knew
who I was months before I decided to
come out and I found out very much like
by accident and there is this kind of
dynamic I don't know if any of you ever
had somebody read your journal or read
somebody else's journal read somebody
else's diary when you weren't supposed
to be doing it but there is this kind of
thing that takes over where people will
read your blog but they don't want to
tell you that they're reading because
that would be too embarrassing to let
you know that they know who you are and
that's a problem for many reasons but
one of them is that in the Academy a
great many people are narcissists
frankly so that so that you know they
imagine yourself even if you're using
pseudonyms like I had one pseudonymous
character in the blog whose name was dr.
grumpo and and he was sort of an amalgam
of of many people I knew and didn't know
and I can't tell you how many people
believed that they were dr. grump oh ok
so so that's a problem two is that
people misunderstand and they miss Reed
and they read themselves into your blog
why should you care about that it's
hurtful
it actually disrupts your real time
relations with people and real world
relations with people in ways that that
aren't in the end productive either
socially or intellectually okay that's
that's I'm amused because i'm going to
say almost all the opposite things he
nobody that I worked with knew that the
blog was me that I know of partly
because I lied about where i was i said
i was in the Upper Midwest in America
and really I was in Ontario and I did
things like you know stuff like that but
when I did come out and start
identifying myself to people I had
people who had been reading the blog and
who thought that someone else was them
so for instance i had the character when
i was still blogging about work who i
used the pseudonym hooker boots for and
he thought hooker boots was someone else
who was a friend of mine i said no
hooker boots was you so instead of
having everybody think that they were
the person everybody felt the person was
somebody else um I didn't have any any I
was very surprised I didn't have any
negative repercussions from the blog and
like I said was extremely careful are
coming out the only negative thing I had
is some crazy person who threatened a
lawsuit but that didn't have anything to
do with my professional stuff if
anything I think that the people who
subsequently found out about the blog a
few grad student friends who did figure
out that it was me were were pleased
with it liked it because one of the
things that I tried to do with it is to
be open about my own ambivalence but not
so much I didn't quit I didn't bitch a
lot about other people I kind of bitched
about my own kind of position in the
Academy and do I really want to be doing
this or not but I was careful about that
even so strangely that said I I too have
become more careful since I'm out but
what I'm more careful about and this
really bothers me is my
private life I'm I'm more careful about
writing about writing honestly about
what I'm doing now that I'm a housewife
then I was as an academic because the
person who I would be writing about
would be my husband right or might you
know people who i am intimate with so
i'm thinking a lot about what that means
in terms of the whole personal public
juxtaposition that I that I like messing
around with in the blog that said
boundaries for untenured academics you
know i would say better safe than sorry
right that sad you know anything that
you write it is a form of publication it
is it is a public statement so that
that's true whether or not you're
pseudonymous whether or not you're
anonymous so I've always am that's why I
think I've always been very careful not
to bitch about people who piss me off I
will talk about the situations that
frustrate me or I'll talk about issues
that bother me but I've always tried to
kind of not personalize them the stuff
that I'll personalizes things that are
funny or when somebody says something I
think is really apropos but I think that
I mean that's just kind of generic sort
of professional professionalism I guess
when I started my blog which I think was
around 2003 oh I was an untenured
professor aina have tenure oh but it was
always a blog under my name is in the
blogspot address that I chose and
although really it was very much just as
a form of writerly play for me it was
vaguely linked in my mind to the fact
that I just published my first novel and
it was clear to me that in them I had
traveled on very little money to be
remember reading for the number of
places but it was clear to me that the
future of book promotion was going to be
very much online and I thought that it
would be useful for me to develop a
blogging voice and instead of blogging
habit like before my next novel was
published so there wasn't trying to
learn in a hurry you know on the spot so
I always had that particular kind of a
public readership in mind that needed to
be tied to my other publishing identity
and i also found very quickly that some
of my first readers were in fact my
students at Columbia both undergraduates
and graduate students and I have gone my
blog which i think is less an academic
blog then as I say a kind of commonplace
book for things that catch my eye that
interest me I have found it an
incredibly valuable instigator of
conversations with people who who I have
other relationships with also but who I
can have a whole second level of
conversation with on the basis of the
things that I ray is on my blog so for
me it would have been it just literally
never occurred to me to blog anonymously
and it also has always seemed to me the
tenure not ten year thing is a bit of a
red herring because in some ways the
strongest obligations you know you have
to have the sort of perhaps the self
respect that involves not bearing your
most painful negative emotions
constantly for everybody to read but
also the kind of respect for other
especially with privacy issues that you
would hope to have for yourself and
certainly you know as a professor i have
known again found a blog post on a
student's blog about a conversation with
me and i certainly would prefer not to
say those but i also feel that I have a
stronger obligation the students privacy
that the student has to my privacy right
so I have always been very careful about
not discussing really most aspects of my
professional life if you think like what
if a candidate who's being interred what
if I'm on a search committee and a
candidate's being interviewed for a job
at Columbia and they're googling the
names of the search committee members
that would be a natural way to do
research you would get told as a job
candidate these five people will be
meeting you at the MLA does that
candidate need to see me saying gosh I
had the most tedious meeting this
afternoon reading these awful file you
know you think about it you think about
that sort of obligation to others and I
find that actually by far the most
constricting set of silencers much less
much more than anything about how people
evaluating my career you know for ten
year would be would be thinking about it
yeah can can you pull up the eastern
blood blog on the screen um so I started
this blog when I was a graduate student
I think in my second year and it's just
it's very it's a very silly science blog
so i think the the top post up there has
to youtube videos about songs about
science and this had absolutely nothing
to do with my research and in the
sciences when you when you work in a lab
as a graduate student you're basically a
very cheap employee so you you're a
student in the sense that you don't you
get paid the stipend but you don't get
vacation and you're you're an employee
in the sense that you're working for
your boss and you were doing the
experiments that gets her the grant to
stay in her job so i started out i used
my first name but not my last name
simply because i didn't want to show up
in google with this silly blog when i
was actually you know working in a lab
and representing my boss
and looking for work but I didn't
realize that there was actually a
faculty member in my department who also
had a blog and he eventually found out
my last name and i think that's that's
how i was out at but at the time I
didn't mind anymore because what happens
in science blogging is that it's over
the year since I started it got more and
more respects and there are several
collectives where scientists are
blogging science blogs com was the first
one I think nature network was the
second one and they invited me to keep a
blog there which is my other blog I
don't know if you want to pull that up
too don't have to and and that is
completely with my full name a first
name last name it was one of their
requirements and their their science
blogging conferences I went to a few
conferences where people just talk about
blogging and what it's like to write
about science and how its seen in the
media the several newspapers use science
various science blogs as their source
for news so it just became more and more
serious and from for me there was no
need to be some pseudonymous at all but
there is that being said there is a big
group of people and they are mainly
women who are blogging anonymously about
their science career and they mostly
write about how hard it is to get tenure
and how hard it is to combine working 60
hours in a lab with raising a child but
I never got to that stage so it's it
just didn't pertain to me something that
I think is kind of emerging I mean it
sounds to me like we're all saying that
blogging well untenured or blogging well
academic is surprisingly and problematic
which is my experience too but I'm kind
of bothered by what I'm feeling like is
kind of this an assumption that we're
all making that there are some things
that are for private discourse and there
are some things that are for public
discourse and you know you say you talk
about them in the bar but you don't talk
about them in public because at least a
big part of what I was trying to do with
my blog was to talk about the anxieties
and I think that that's why you get
questions like
that you know is it as a grad student or
as someone who's untenured is it safe
for me to blog there's a lot of neurosis
narcissism whatever you want to call it
the academics have particularly preten
your academics and a lot of us job
market stuff and and all of that but I
think the more open we collectively are
about that kind of thing the better as
you know as you were saying it is for
everybody that it turns out that it's
something that everybody shares and to
me that was part of what was
surprisingly unproblematic about being
an academic blogging is that I wasn't
really voicing anything that was that
unique so I just kind of want to throw
something throw a caution in there that
the whole you know these these are
things that you should keep private
presumption is is one that I want people
to not just accept uncritically I guess
I wonder if I could sort of jump on that
too because I think one of the things
being a blogger has really raised for me
is what is public and what is private
and specifically for women i mean i
think it's a it's a really important
feminist question i think it's a really
important question for queers that we
aren't actually permitted privacy in the
sense that you know more established
people in the community are permitted
privacy I mean you know one of the
things that people talk about for
example and that i've recently gotten
into a tussle with some some bloggers
about is Parenthood okay okay yeah i
mean his parenting private hustle as an
understatement that the internet was
exploding with iron in responding to a
person Clara and and tears and you know
there was great distress and and there
were sort of two related problems one
was I was annoyed because the post i had
put up from my point of view was not
really about parents and I was like why
do you people have to put yourself in
the middle of everything all the time
but but the question that was being
raised was you know why isn't parenthood
something that is is a public issue you
know and and that we as parents are
always being and they argue that I had
actually taken this stance that
parenthood is a problem for a larger
public or its figured that way in the
Academy rather than being figured as
something that needs to be solved right
and so where is the private and where is
the public when you when you are
apparent in the Academy with our crazy
schedules and the expectation that you
will work until the job is done and and
I also think for women I mean you know
one of the big themes in the blogosphere
is you know how do people perceive me
I'm making a great generalization here
but I mostly see women talking about
that I don't see men talking about that
and so are women ever allowed privacy
really when they're being scrutinized
like that I think is a big question well
I was one of the people who commented on
that post and then later got into with
dr. crazy who's a friend of mine about
the parenting thing and I think you're
you're exactly right that it and it's
not just the job versus the private but
it's it's this presumption that we have
that work is over here and everything
else is over here you know whether
that's your family your sexuality your
gender your you know status as a parent
or not a parent whatever and that those
two things should always be separate and
I think that you know again you know as
a feminist that's a problematic
assumption so yeah I have yet to blog on
that but I've been thinking about I'm
gonna get there now this is a good time
for us to take a question this is a
somewhat flipping your previous question
on its head and asking about what about
the possibility going either now or in
the future you're blogging becoming
something that is actually respected and
I know
Claire you have no respect for tenure
but for everybody else who might might
not have it yet that that might actually
be a form of publication that might be
rewarded in tenure and I'd be interested
in hearing the panel's ideas on that
including people who already have tenure
I mean just a very quick word on this I
think it's very use a blog is very
useful as a broadcasting mechanism for
one's academic work I don't want to take
a super conservative line on this but
you know in terms of what I do on my
blog I'm not honestly writing things I
write very off-the-cuff that's the
pleasure of it I can just write and then
it's out there so I certainly find it
very useful for facilitating scholarly
communication I link to something that
I've published somewhere else and it
makes it easier for an academic in India
to write me an email and ask if I could
send him the PDF file of my book you
know like it very much facilitates that
sort of scholarly communication and
scholarly community but you know from my
point of view I don't it I would think
that the the community building aspect
of blogging is more strikingly what
could or should be counted than the
actual writing itself that I would think
that the kind of in the sense that
blogging you know that the tenured
radical blog you're doing something
there that's awfully like service to the
discipline that's like serving on a
committee for the MLA or you know
whatever something like that so for me
it would be more likely to that I would
think it would be likely that we would
see that recognized sooner by tenure and
review committees than actual writing
per se I think what you're saying about
racial the racial aspect of the
private-public distinction actually one
of my I have two of my co bloggers a
woman of color but the one woman who is
the most what the one who wants to write
the most about racial issues is also one
who's the least comfortable doing so and
the few times when she does
you know she's kind of complained to the
either she gets very little comments or
that the comments instantly get derailed
into you know kind of predictable lines
and yet I'm thinking about other blogs i
read like post Bujji is a really good
one where those kind of conversations do
happen and the kind of talking about
feelings and stuff does happen and I
don't know I think there's something
there about you know kind of a feeling
of critical mass right that like because
the feminist blogosphere or the feminist
academic blogosphere has kind of gotten
to the point where we have panels on
this sort of thing and everybody knows
everybody is and stuff that they're
there is that sense of comfort in a way
that I don't think bloggers of color my
perception is our are quite there yet I
don't know maybe I'm wrong but I would
just add on a slightly different note I
think you know it can be it these things
can look for things are changing so
quickly in terms of social practices and
so forth I was having a conversation
recently with a good friend of mine
who's probably eight or nine years
younger than me and she was she was a
very active blogger when she and she's
in graduate school now she was a very
active blogger when she was an
undergraduate but actually sort of lost
her confidence as a blogger as a
graduate student because that stage of
moving from let's say during coursework
in a ph.d program into becoming a
dissertation writer having a
dissertation project that is a very
costly developmental stage in many ways
a lot of students temporarily lives
their voice and have to find it again
and the blogging can feel suddenly much
higher stakes and more stressful i think
especially for people who have been
blogging under their own names who come
to internalize all of these sort of
censoring mechanisms that have to do
with what will other people think about
me if you know if they read me writing
in in a non scholarly voice when I
haven't yet established myself as
writing successfully and publicly in a
scholarly boys and so she was sort of
ironically referring to herself as part
of a lost generation of bloggers but
I do think that via these factors can
operate very strongly on certain groups
for all sorts of reasons well I would
also say I want to throw two different
things in here it is very very easy as a
white woman who writes about race a lot
in her blog it's very easy to get mobbed
by you know wandering groups of very
difficult people and and I I became a
magnet for some of those people because
of a blog called Durham in Wonderland
which is run by a guy named casey
johnson at brooklyn college and that
blog has a reputation for turning loose
groups of i don't i don't even know how
to describe them but they're basically
like right-wing libertarians and one of
their themes is that if you write about
race at all you are a racist i mean
bottom line and and they're responsible
for actually a lot of damaging stuff and
so there is a group of bloggers out
there who is rightly afraid of these
people i mean because one of the things
that happens is when they lock on to you
for example they started writing letters
to the board of trustees at Wesleyan and
writing letters to my colleagues I mean
actual letters not just email you know
and letters to the president and so on
you know in that kind of you know we
have to get these radicals out of the
Academy blah blah blah unfortunately i
work at wesley and write some people
would just go hahahahaha Claire's done
it again
but but you know a lot of people are a
lot more vulnerable than I am and they
work at places that that care a lot more
about about their public image so I
think I think race is very fraud in the
blogosphere now to sort of address the
other question as a historian technology
is a real paradox for historians because
on the one hand there's a whole group of
people like Josh Freeman and Steve
Breyer at the American social history
project Roy Rosen's like the late worry
Rosen's like down at George Mason who
did amazing things with technology
before it was popularized in the ways it
was so historians have really been kind
of at the forefront of Technology and
the profession as a whole has really not
dealt with electronic publication period
so blogging dealing with blogging is way
down the line when the profession can't
even agree as to whether a refereed
online journal should count for your
tenure case okay and so it's very much
field by field and there is no broader
discussion that I'm aware of in
universities about how to come to terms
with our new reality which is that
without money a lot less is going to be
published and particular fields are
going to take really major hits like
European history for example is going to
take a huge hit I just want to get back
to the question about whether blogging
can be beneficial for getting tenure it
there are actually several people in
science blogging who who put it in there
on their CV under outreach activities
and when that is part of the required
tenure package then it's it definitely
is beneficial especially if they're
there with their full name and
affiliation on the front page they're
basically promoting their University far
wider than they ever could and for free
and another thing is this is for me the
third time that I've been invited to
publicly speak on a panel or give a talk
that is the direct result of having a
blog and while the blog itself is not a
messy
v these things definitely are so it can
start other projects that are more
respected than just having a website
somewhere on the internet that anyone
can start yeah I think that that's my
sense of it is that it it functions well
in terms of kind of service or other
publications like it's not going to
count as a as a you know refereed
publication I like Michael Baer obeys
distinction between raw writing and
cooked writing right it's blogging is
kind of the raw and then the kind of
refereed journal stuff is the cooked
stuff I work for magazine and you know
we are caught up in a new cycle since
your blogs are for the public and
there's this Pope to be more widely read
than just within your academic
communities like do you feel pressure to
jump into the new cycle do you feel ever
that you missed like something was a
week too late because it already made
the front page of the New York Times
like if so how do you deal with it like
what you know what's that like I try to
stay ahead of Boing Boing and they one
of their writers actually reads my blog
once in a while and they've picked up a
few things from my blog I never get a
lot of hits back because I'll just be
the little credit link at the bottom but
it makes me feel so good when I know it
was on my side first um actually I I
think I get more hits when I get linked
to bitch PhD then when I get linked to
CNN which is really impressive but but i
would i would say two things one is I
don't write about something if i don't
think i can write responsibly about it
and i think i wish in fact i were the
kind of blogger like you are actually
who can do something in a paragraph and
have it be really short really incisive
and just put it out there bang i have a
tendency to ruminate a little more so
that for example the post that's up
right now is on caster semenya the the
runner
from from South Africa who has fallen
into this whole gender testing thing and
it's transgender issues are things I've
thought about a lot as a queer studies
professor and it's really difficult to
figure out how to talk about them with
an audience who isn't with the program
it's a good exercise to how do you
actually communicate this in language
that your average educated reader can
understand but I also wanted to do it
responsibly and I wanted to connect it
to some bigger historical issues and
when I figured out that I could connect
it to sexism in women's sports and
homophobia in sports more generally over
the over the course of the last quarter
century then I figured out how to do it
and I didn't mind that I was behind the
news cycle because I actually thought
very few people were saying anything
smart about her at all and that much
that was being said was was deeply
offensive to me and really racist as
well so so that when I figured out what
the smart thing was to say that was that
was fine to be late as far as I was
concerned I would see myself that's
sitting more on a beside of it in that
i'm always greedy for good links like I
my god that's a really good one and
obviously the viral nature of Internet
communication is such that if there is
something really cool like it quickly
will be all over the place so i always
get really grumpy in august and over
holidays because all of the all of the
places online that usually i can count
on for good links everyone's on vacation
and they're just using their stuff that
they had in the files that wasn't quite
thrilling enough to publish so I'm like
let this holiday weekend be over where
my good links so my posting would be not
not at all on the model of Alexandra's I
would have more like you know a brief
post everyday or perhaps even as many as
three or four that that often are in
fact built around a link to something
that then prompts you know a thought I
sometimes schedule small posts when I
know I'm not going to be able to write
for a long time so of course they're
already way behind the news because I
wrote them maybe a month ago so
more general things but it just as a
feeler so that people will keep coming
back because I have because I read a lot
of political blogs and do a little bit
of political blogging I think a lot
about new cycle stuff and I've just kind
of come to realize that you know I'm not
a journalist I'm not doing any reporting
I'm not doing any actual investigation
so to some extent either I'm just kind
of saying here's a link to something you
know that really makes me mad or
sometimes I'll post about stuff well
after the new cycle because as you say
there's more time to think about it but
I'm aware of it but I just I don't care
I'm just curious about commenting how
you how you deal with it do you accept
them raw do they pull you into topics
unexpectedly and do you feel like it's
an obligation as a blogger to go comment
on other blogs i would say sometimes i
don't have time to comment on other
blogs although I do have a group of
blogs that I follow regularly and read
regularly I don't comment that
frequently I think because I try to
limit my time on the computer as you
know it blogging can really expand the
amount of time you sit there putting off
other things that actually really need
to be done like showering and eating and
and so on so so I do i do try not to get
caught up in other things I do think
there's a phenomenon to wear commenters
sort of carry a conflict they're having
on one blog over to another blog you
know and it's almost as if they're
moving from place to place and and that
can be distressing I I do and and you
run into a lot of problems with this I
do delete comments and I have a
statement up on my blog about the
conditions under which I delete comments
and basically it's if I think they're
abusive and it's it's a call I have to
make but I don't let people come back
over and over again
say horrible things about me I don't let
them make accusations against other
people because those things do remain up
online you know so that if somebody you
know says eric foner did blah blah blah
blah blah you know you google eric foner
it's going to come up eventually you
know so I'm actually very aware of how
other people's reputations might be
impacted by space on giving to somebody
else I think the other thing to remember
and this this makes it very different
from at least certain kinds of
journalism makes a lot more like fox
news to tell you the truth is that
people become obsessive on the internet
so that one of the things you run into
in comments and one of the things i know
i can certainly fall prey to is ending
up in a kind of back and forth where the
points that are really being made are
only marginally different from but you
know you sit there thinking okay he
really doesn't understand and i'm really
going to get it right this time and and
i think i think it's a waste of time in
truth i just want to add one more thing
without hogging this space which is i
think people see a lot more potential
around the exchange of ideas in the
blogosphere then then there really is at
this moment if my sense is that people
often comment not because you've changed
their mind about anything but because
they like you already and they have
something to add to it or you know
they're coming back to say their point
of view but there's not a whole lot of
listening in the blogosphere from my
perspective i might just add i mean a
couple minor points i would say that
it's been noticeable to me over the last
couple years as more people shift or
reading blogs let's say through a feed
reader like google reader or something
like that it actually it certainly makes
it much less likely that i'll comment on
someone's blog if i'm just reading
through the feet i might like a post but
i would have to feel the impulse to go
there especially to comment and i
actually see myself as now being much
more likely to just write an email to
the author in response so that it's back
to the sense of a conversation between
bloggers and
individual reader rather than a
conversation in a communal space so that
you might think of it as being that now
there's a proportion of blogs that have
very active even if nobody's listening
to each other comment sections with
strings of hundreds of comments but i
would think that as a smaller blog like
mine you know I've continued to build up
readership definitely but I notice much
fewer regular commenters than a couple
years ago just because of this change in
the culture of reading and I also see
that I just have a lot of email
correspondences with the people who once
would have been commenters CII to me I
think participating in the comments
section is kind of is important is a big
deal both because like you all delete
comments like I'll please my comments
and my comment policy is you know if
it's obnoxious alt delete it and that's
it like I'm not going to explain what I
mean by that so I mean and I use that to
keep down the like big flame wars and
stuff but to me ultimately blogging is
really it's it's a social medium and
that's why I say you know academically
it its service maybe it's it's you know
advertisement for your university or
your department but comment you know
being participating in comments and
responding to the people who participate
in my comment threads to me is part of
that building that that social aspect
and the trust that then enables people
hopefully to listen and actually
converse on my Eastern Bloc blog I don't
get a lot of comments because I feel
throughout the spam and ninety percent
of them are just spam things that frying
me through google but on the other blog
on Nature Network I get a lot more
comments even though there is actually a
procedure that you have to have an
account there before you're even allowed
to leave a comment so it's it
discourages people who just randomly
find you in Google and want to say
something nasty because now they have to
spend five minutes typing in their name
and email address but because you have
to have an account there's this entire
community that all comments on each
other's blogs and the front page even
has a list of the most commented blog so
it's
they're not actively trying to get on
the list but being on the list is quite
an honor because now your blog shows out
like right off on top of the page so
there are a lot of discussions going on
on one blog that continued on another
blog and the danger of it is that it can
lead to a bit of cliquish pneus where
people who do just come in to comment on
one blog find themselves stuck in a
discussion that they can't really follow
because this is this group of people
that all read each other's blogs and I
think you might have that in your fields
as well we certainly have time for a
couple more questions I think we've got
almost 10 minutes more so I urge those
of you who have something on your mind
to go ahead and ask hi I've heard you
mention links a couple of times and I'm
wondering if you actively reach out so
that people can find you or you just I
know that you're well-known bloggers
here but if somebody were starting one
how would they have what people find
them if they're not based on an
institution I was thinking that actually
with the previous question to that I
have now had a number of friends or
students or whoever has start up a blog
and then say but no one's reading me and
I say well what blogs do you read it and
they say none like well obviously you
know so in other words i also have a a
triathlon training blog and so that's a
different blogosphere that i have been a
part of and that's where you see really
clearly i leave much i leave comments
much more frequently on triathlon blogs
because someone says I had a terrible
workout and I have this race and I'm
worried about it and I say don't worry
it'll be foot you know so that the
community feel of it is very strong
there and it was clear to me excited
that blog up much more recently it was
it was clear to me that you know really
commenting on someone else's blog with
that link back to your blog and there's
some appropriate overlap between the two
is really the way to solidly build some
kind of a readership over time there's
no replacement for that I think yeah I
mean a lot of the blogs that I follow I
found because someone left a comment
that i found interesting you know they
said something intelligent or pointed
out something I haven't thought of or
whatever and I go
on the little homepage link and then and
I try to throw links to people who I
know are not big bloggers yet I think
that's true I think some of the online
journals that are attached to two paper
journals or some of the journals that
are just online like inside higher ed is
a much more sort of loosey-goosey type
of publication it's totally online they
link a lot of blogs you know if you ever
get linked to Inside Higher ad everybody
reads you I mean you'll just see a huge
jump right there and if you're looking
for blogs to read going on inside higher
ed is really important because they have
a number of regular blogs that are
hosted there but then there's also
section where they will link you know
two or three posts every day of
something they found that's worth
reading it's also true that if you write
something and link to say The Chronicle
of Higher ad or link to the New Yorker
or something like that they'll find you
because that's what site meter does ok
if you have a site meter on your blog it
records the addresses that that people
came to came to you from ok so if you
are linking other places eventually
somebody's going to notice and this is
how I've gotten linked to like the
National Review which was a somewhat
peculiar experience and and CNN fox news
I got linked to its you know you link to
something if they're getting a lot of
hits from your blog invariably they're
going to go and say what is this and and
keep an eye on you and which i think is
actually one of the most enticing things
about blogging nowadays because it's
simply true that with fewer and fewer
print publications it's harder to get
published it's particularly hard to get
published in a way the people who aren't
academics are going to read you just
regular intelligent readers
that's a really big change in the last
quarter century it's also really big
change that you need so many connections
to get published in a place like the
nation or you know it places where you
want to be read by say like-minded
individuals or the National Review if
your conservative and to get published
in the National Review as a liberal
would be unheard of right so so I think
there is some potential more potential
than there is with paper publications
nowadays for those links actually
allowing you to be read by people who
will take an interest in you people who
wouldn't ordinarily find you in the
world I'm also noticing that we've all
get talked about passive ways of getting
yourself noticed leave a comment and
then you know hopefully someone will
follow you and I want to kind of I'm
like maybe this is because we're all
women to to also say email someone and
say I've written you know I write about
this here's a link if it's a
conversational enough email and isnt
spamming sounding people will usually
follow it and I've definitely had people
who have brought blogs my attention or
post to my attention that were things
that they knew that I would be
interested in because of what I write
about and then I'll usually do a post
and say oh look at this interesting blog
about such and such so you know that's
the other thing is just ask as someone
who blocks off in about books I get a
lot of really annoying from basically
promotional emails I hate getting emails
from publicists who don't have a good
sense of what I would actually be likely
to read and write about but I almost
more hate getting emails from authors of
books who are inappropriately sort of
pitching me in some sense and it's it
really makes me feel very negative so I
would actually say like if I would I
would be much more likely to come to
someone's blog if they left a comment a
couple times and I thought well who is
this person this is interesting if they
sent me an email that said hi I'm mess
and I started up a new blog it's worthy
of your attention I would not be very
likely to go there see well that kind of
emails what i mean by spammy like it's
kind of vague and you could send it out
to 37 people but if it's something like
I've been falling it's awesome if it's
clearly a personal email I would
probably follow it well you know I would
also say and this was a total accident
really that one of the reasons my blog
got a lot of readership very fast as I
wrote a lot of posts that were aimed at
graduate students who were on the job
market and a lot of sort of advice for
for those who were job seekers and those
posts got spread around really really
fast because graduate students even in a
very competitive market place like this
one are basically much more invested in
their communities than people who aren't
graduate students and they're much more
invested in each other's success often
then then faculty are and so they spread
them around and eventually that's sort
of actually quite quickly that
percolated up to graduate advisors
because there is of course a whole thing
going on in the job market where you
know potential candidates are being
produced by institutions that are unlike
the institution that is ultimately going
to hire them right and so there are all
kinds of people giving them advice about
how to get jobs you know that's totally
inappropriate because they've actually
never worked at the place that would
give their graduates due to the job
right so so as somebody who has run many
many search committees in my life I had
I would say 10 or 15 really really
focused posts that were aimed at that
group in particular so the lesson I
would draw from that is establishing
some kind of a theme very early on for
your blog gives you the possibility of
actually picking up the readers that you
want well perhaps we'll just all stick
around for a few minutes and can take
individual questions but thanks again I
think the sponsors of the event and to
this wonderful group of panelists thank
you very much
you